it's 5:00 in the morning
today we are going to the river Ganges
to perform the last rites enter Monique
for my grandfather and deposit his ashes
into the river it's such a difference
from New Delhi yesterday because that
was like totally Yang and this is total
again one thing that I struggle with a
lot is like worrying over planning today
I saw something so special in the unique
fusion of messiness and beauty all the
crazy wild animals and then this
happened there's a cow right there
seeing all the crowds of people in this
bridge this looks like a storybook you
guys feel the bridge moving I was here
when I was 3 years old and I remember
vaguely that I had a really hard time
getting on the bridge because I was so
scared and my father just grabbed me and
I was screaming and he took me across I
was expecting the last rites ceremony to
be very sad but I was surprised with how
much peace and closure it gave me the
tragic event of my grandfather's sudden
death incited my first trip to India and
in coming here I have seen a glimpse
into the hard work and sacrifices my
grandfather made to create the best life
for our family I feel a responsibility
now to work even harder for my dreams
and to fulfill the path my grandfather
paved for me we just finished the
ceremony for my grandfather really god I
came to do it
some closure but I'm still processing
I love how colorful this country is both
literally and metaphorically how in this
culture something is sad terrifying and
mournful as someone's death is
remembered in a beautiful celebration of
their life you never really know how
special something or someone is until
they're gone
sometimes you have to travel halfway
around the world to discover that I
challenge you today to tell a friend or
a family member how much you love and
appreciate them because you might not
even be aware of the sacrifices they
have made for you until they're gone
Wow